For what I propose we do is that we have been with Rosemary
and on going down to them once each panel speaker has a chance to say anything further pump as I mentioned,
we am proceed to questions and discussion. After we finish at three o'clock potential to save it.
I think the papers today demonstrate what a wonderful tapestry when asked that are interweaving of so many ideas
and inspiration to many developments that shape our society the centuries
and today I contributions of all these fine gentlemen on the panel
and am very grateful to have been asked of the discipline to the hat that up to one years I've certainly will modify
the maybe just to a that in the broker I spoke to someone about civics education.
She is involved in occasion and she referred to the work I've done in the program,
called the discovering democracy is under the Howard government which ended up with materials being circulated to all
schools
and the result of that relates to a comment that to David made about the absence of constitutional history in the
schools I would say is wide and that its political and constitutional history,
we have a lot of material in the books and activities we circulated
and which was designed in her fairly accessible way to talk about traditional arrangements
and have about our political history that it was those sections that the teachers were not interested in what they are
interested in cheaply is encouraging students to be disciplined soon in the political process which is which is fine
and they would get up a petition to get a skateboard park. For instance, there are no approach the Council on this.
This is good, they would learn that it is the council you asking, not the Prime Minister and so on,
so it it's her a valuable to do, but what I would ask teachers why why aren't you doing this other stuff.
Now they say they are too boring, and if students need to know it.
They'll find out later and I would say you know you teach quadratics equations you teach profit
and loss you teach that the periodic table, you do all those things, but you won't explain to the students
or have them learn the each state since the same number of Senators to Canberra,
but for the House of Representatives you send numbers according to the population to be stated to pretty fundamental
aspect of our Constitution
and relevant to the business of being voters so I think there is a long way to go the before we can say that there is a
good civics education program in the school and its partner nothing because for so long.
Nothing has been done so now
when talking about a generation of teachers who don't know this stuff if we were here years ago, teachers
and students would all know some British Constitutional history year they would know Magna Carta
and Charles the first losing his head and death in the glorious Revolution
and so they have a sort of outline Rajesh Constitutional development, which explains why you still have a king
or a Governor General, who is the only acts on advice, the Parliament
or of ministers responsible department that elementary aspect system,
you would have learnt through British history that doesn't happen so nothing happens so that's a rather despairing
comment on this glorious occasion they have actually given me something to comment about a comment is this led to we
have a course in high schools school legal studies
and legal studies teachers are very proactive in including a lot of civics education
and those sorts of matters under the heading of legal studies and that there are a very young, well motivated,
energetic bunch of teachers and they have an annual conference,
which I would rest for the last eight years in the business
and which brings about two hundred of these people into the one room
and the exchanges are fantastic so as not all bad news at a hole under the Parliamentary edging patient website have a
wealth of material arm and more boys, including historical material so you can find you a short history of Parliament.
For example, on the PO website and they are currently life the anniversary this year,
developing materials on Carter 's ratification dwellers range of other so I don't know that there is the general course
to disband one eleven.
There are gatherings like this and groups of people promoting civics education
and proper education for our school student in the life remains on the stated discontinuance education theme.
I think with video link.
Further income some reasonably educated in relation to the town clerk to John mentioned are Rosemary 's uncomfortably
close to the Parliamentary precinct is certainly within the Parliamentary trials on looking at you are and an arm.
It may be, in fact the responsibility of the Museum of Australian democracy, I don't know the harm my strongest he was.
It is just wrong and end arm. It is fundamentally misconceived. What extraordinary place.
This was in the early days of colony are now in a couple of respects and in I mention cable
and Sinclair in government quarry appointing ex-convict snarling ladies were shaken their heads in light of both as
someone already regain arm.
Clinically safe and have follows through a thing to really when you think about it harm that case
and you know the superstructure that was put in place by Sydney to give the possibility of emerging that that was armed
right at the forefront of of our you have fallen more in governments
and continually instantly knocking you referring David of unit two, so Mum and initiatives here around the boat
and all sort of thing. It's a very, very sought a proud record of leading the world and one thing respect.
We were leaving and the English-speaking world.
From the third month settlement is,
and that with great respect is not reflected in a far as you have started to go wrong.
The second step is the something less like the look, the Senator Senator Senate has a wonderful budget
and you just point out that my readers very unpopular in government circles at the time because he refused to permit
any separate funds to be deployed to fund the monument in Mac based on the basis that Parliament had appropriated funds
to the Senate Department for the purpose of supporting centres and that this was a purpose not mention by will.
It is a question without notice.
Rosemary you following the precedent
or not to use them at they are guards take one substantive" is in my paper I actually talk about which we tend to
remain carrying him glowing terms all the wonderful things in the result of back out from the eighteen forties through
the nineteen fifty was used between Catholics and Protestants letter writers
and newspapers in this country argue about the car, because as we heard the neck
and England was Catholic country fish
and sundry are Catholics in Australia said well actually it with the Catholics who brought liberty to Australia because
of Langton with a Catholic unpromising controversialist course would having any of this.
They point out the first of all, the Pope did another of the capital antifreedom
and then they try re- badge Langton has Freeborn Englishman are her own English patriot he was visiting interference
elsewhere so that another side to them even car that story, it isn't always about the wonderful things.
It is principally about that, but there are other components to other another couple of things to say.
I think our pendulum know more about this and I didn't.
I understand that the first government was famous for proclaiming that will be noticeably green/ this is a time
and slavery still exist to the British Empire.
That's another in important component of freedom you can buy and sell human beings are in this country
and the other the other.
Another major innovation just to give you another example in the eighteen fifties Australian colonies came up with the
idea of the other sumo government in talks
and contract under claims against the government are legislation out with another ninety years until such Crown
proceedings were available in England,
to underline the point that several people have made that the transmission of ideas.
Yes, we get a lot of ideas involve institutional investor one-way traffic or thank you am any questions. Any comments.
Yes you will a year will only two bit like believing in the tooth fairy and
when we discover what it is very really is a it's over, I think gives us either.
I think it's gets the idea is that of the gum associated with this document or documents with this event arm,
whether those ideas are accurate is another matter that there become associated with them has become a method it if it
is a legend
and make lots of elections people become very emotionally attached to live in is not absolutely rigourously intellectually
attached to say I think. It's exactly right. On the other thing.
At least this nothing wrong with at all mean age degeneration you know owns and runs the place.
Lisa say it to the schoolkids from my lecturers becoming am always at places like you that were twelve -year-old in
five years time.
All sixties time you will be bugging reset after that you were running the show,
I mean each generation sees things in their own way and and and one thing about Magna Carta,
whether understood promptly and understood properly by people and experts debate all sides.
What I think means anyway so you debate has many views that are all in a way valid attached to am if Magna Carta is
seen to symbolise good things and I think it does not never that anybody say that Magna Carta symbolises bad
or things that are against the public interest always associated with an good government and have the rule of law
and isolate people seem likely,
just fantastic cultural icon that almost irrespective of words in ten have attracted all of those with the best about
major phrases like and to us they are that the other way and you go the whole year,
that track your beautiful illuminated those rich colours and it just blows just cultural residents.
I think it of much level is I think the other young horses… a very simple compelling story teller to children because
what nation they have here we may start very thing you very powerful.
They gave you of King
and Queen being always subject to buy some ministers that something quite if you start with a simple notion of a human
being.
and Then you have a story of people being able to hold the key to what that means in law at the fact that it is over to
within weeks doesn't take away from that dramatic,
so I think is very telling the people of all understand David to say this, I mention before about the elements,
the rule of law on this.
It is institutional arrangements is also some mentality which is nice behind the constants concept example of
moderation in politics that though there are divisions will know between parties infections.
It's all operates within a basic framework which we century except as requiring piece
and has as a peaceful system was a church or said to two cheers for democracy,
or whatever it is not perfect system is like any human contrivance it's created by humans are fallible creatures
and so the sum of similar institutions,
but we have moderation is an idea emerges in sixteen seventies in this course is very important to have disagreement
without having a civil war, which is an enormous achievement historically
and as I wrote it in my paper how to save now it's worth reflecting that we are doing today are clear.
I manner about the achievement given that we have mastered like all the answers civil peace in this country as of other
democracies and if you can on your television, you'll find other parts of the world with a simply have not done this.
Now the at the achievement is enormous.
It's true that the media last blower 's personality scandals all acts of stuff there may seem peacefully voting is a
bit of a chore a bit boring,
but it's an enormous civilisation achievement I think as with stress that we think you were first saw the white shirt
you are in view of the zone as they are the fire is in the as you view as it is our earlier than usual only is there
are all your life.
The any responses well it's not just those two instances,
there are many examples presumption of innocence being reversed about criminal Law where the onus is put on to the
defendant to establish some matter of excuse and it's been a progressive process" a long period of time and firm.
You one of the very obvious examples is where if you are found in possession of more than a certain quantity of a
prohibited drug.
The onus passes to you to prove that you did not have that drug in your possession for the purpose of supply,
otherwise you will be convicted of supplying the drug even if you didn't supply to anyone and that is one example.
There are other examples is no doubt that Parliament has the power to do this, but every time they do it.
They go against the very well established principle with the presumption of innocence
and the requirement from proof being form the party making the allegation so we see inroads into this in in small ways,
and sometimes larger ways are on regret to say fairly constantly and while agencies in the community object.
Every time this happens bar Association more Society Civil Liberties various other bodies academics are Parliament has
the power to do it if they think their votes.
It will go,
but I think I have Professor subpoena prime offender in some of this arm moving moving surfboard from twelve fifteen
thousand one one thousand my favourite auspices some Alexis Cockle
and our democracy in America were wonderful two-volume work of almost a thousand pages if you read the Penguin edition
EE goes speaking in terms of the United States in eight in the eighteen thirties town where he talks about all these
apparent contradictions and you know how many many aspects of the tyranny of the majority which some degrees,
what in our government that has a majority in the Parliament
and is arguably doing winding in so overriding some of these principles,
but there are a lot of things that are in fundamental conflict which Nagin never absolutely reconcile on why the other
items are
and you know it's interesting looking at his book democracy in America because in some ways these days are like Magna
Carta and people seeing democracy in America, whatever they were seeing democracy ( balm, goldplated, W.
Bush will quite a while or a normal quoted are now your recording walk later but that it is its,
it's just very instructive in seeing how release them issues are constantly play against each other and an end.
You know how the rule.
The majority is often in conflict with all the ninth of the highest level writer on insulin as anyone else wish to
comment on this question I shouldn't factor in anthropology officer either you about those particular policy changes,
but some I do say that the fees are decisions made by our lawmakers in our system of representative democracy,
we have elected people to confirm and make outdoors
and wish we just hope that they will make more in the knowledge that what they are doing has a historical legal context,
and done in that there are many reactions to such proposals to to limit apparently limit our right
and one of the great vehicles for expressing those users through Parliamentary committees.
We have great system Parliamentary committee throughout the country where people do have an opportunity to put their
view on the record, and we also have some specialist committees around the various jurisdictions in Australia
and overseas that have a particular role to you keep an eye out for these issues to keep an eye out for potential
infringements of people 's rights and liberties
and to draw them to the attention of the other lawmakers so that at least the decisions,
even though we all know there may numbers for to pursue political agendas least of that material.
They're available for the to educate and inform the lawmakers in every week sent for example,
the little body called the scrutiny of bills that reports on every deal is considered by the Commonwealth Parliament
against phenomena criteria when the VL measure after this, and if the committee feels that the built measure.
Then hit it engages in correspondence with the status to seek at least explanation of why this policy are being
followed half and
and possibly education Amendment of the policy to bring back to the norms that we expect Indian democracy,
I think one thing is very clear and that is at the end of the day and the Australian system,
how he is the will of the majority of people
and found John Hirst mentioned earlier by Mister Menzies can be business around them
and declaring that in relation to one the Communist Party and so forth the end of the day that
when some through through the Parliament one.
Five High Court and then ultimately was resolved against what Menzies want to do in a referendum so again today.
We've been everywhere else you ultimately am assuming someone prepared to put questions we can put a question to it
comes back to ultimately a referendum question,
and now that's resolved one wins a majority that the majority of states are so,
so the people you are in excess of the ultimate say in a general way might be to general elections could be seen in
similar terms, they should say that defective Menzies in a very bad light.
Here he was very reluctant about having to reverse the onus of proof
and his reason for doing so was otherwise the ACO agents have to give evidence publicly and soap,
then they would purposes rationale in that case,
speaking for looking at all the instances that are now being mentioned of onus of proof have been reversed.
I was wrong to think and Nicholas can comment on this. Why why this is happening.
I wondered if it is happening because the standards of guilty beyond reasonable doubt.
We probably race that to such a high level.
Some people are guilty and get off and is that the reason why Parliament has now moved the other way,
said you have to prove your innocence group that wanted to know why you are wide
and agreement move that more people are escaping me just deserts and used to be the case.
In fact the figures haven't changed much decade here in terms of the percentage of people who go to a defendant trial
who are acquitted remained pretty much the same level for a very very long time and
and I think quite an acceptable level, citing work were doing alright.
There might think,
then the reason why the onus of proof is reversed in these cases is so that politicians being tough on crime as opposed
to being smart on crime want to get the message across to those who are going to vote for them in the next election,
which is all of them really interested with a few a few exceptions,
perhaps all right a few exceptions are they think that those people are going to interpret this as a sign that they are
being tough on crime and because they're being tough, therefore,
the courts must be given the weapons with which to be tough
and the devil take the the individual who is caught up in the process used to date a case we have another question.
This area you will many say something union expense in the nineteen twenties many Minnesota proposes international
Magna Carta day larger English-speaking countries that Australia was one in Australia actually embraces as it easier
then in nineteen thirty nine.
The movement sure worried to maybe about prone germinal neutral sentiment in America Centre at the Lincoln copy of the
Magna Carta to the New York welfare party and there was actually at the most popular thing to be seen.
There are, and when the war broke out was stuck on the other side of the Atlantic.
So was taken Fort Knox for our safety are Magna Carta incidentally used to be spelt Magna Charter H which is
when you do your research in both spellings category and I are okay,
you are value ninety forty six the British Museum was changed to allow Magna Carta now to remain one more year in
America in gratitude for the American assistance of the word charter chart of United Nations nine accidents chart of
the Commonwealth.
Not an accident charter of rights and responsibilities Victoria act two thousand seven not an accident.
So the workers flowed into our language and other subtle ways and was designed.
I just had this too many cars found in popular culture,
so I was in my research I found all these references do a racehorse called Mehmet Carter in South Australia,
Victoria nineteen twenties and thirties associate is a very live horse
and it had the advantage of famously beating an Australian
and Victorian political drongo as you know is one of the Macquarie dictionary derivations for the work you're a dumb
person in Australia, which I think is a worker should be brought in the use.
That's my opinion as driver being faced the fact that it is light was last lost last in every race
and then in twenty thirteen out Jay-Z is beyond those other half produced at a record album called Magna Carta
committee launched to the need when he went to see this Aaron are married cartilages out of Salisbury Cathedral
and that she had their copy on display are: the Zelman cover, so it is clear
and easily an initial high heavy rock group in the nineteen nineties Magna Carta.
There are lots of barristers chambers around the Commonwealth will make the Carter outputs gone along way from a
chartered twelve fifteen the names still around
and even the word charter Helena Eleanor risen above in nineteen forty eight talking about the universal declaration of
human rights,
described it as a Magna Carta for the whole of mankind Pegasus question the back there as you get closer to home.
You laugh at other harbour
or she is going to issue there has been a debate for the last four years in England about me doing the Constitution at
a conference last in London on the card I attended there
and then pivot University College London who are writing a kind of home Internet survey to ask Britain's what things
should go into a new Magna Carter, now that this is as it
or not for the using is an occasion to stimulate an interest in constitutional matters that what shall say I don't
really have a letter to your value as he has set its education years in I've been held to be too gloomy i.e.
I think I am more gloomy because just the other day I met up again with the Kerry Jones,
who ran the case for the Queen.
We had a republican referendum that I was on the other side, as is often the case,
you get to know the people on the other side and you like them better than the people on your side, so I linked to.
I still speak to Kerry occasionally she has been running an outfit called the constitutional education fund
and I'm a member and she was in despair and she follows this through the code,
the Lowy Institute Poly about people 's attitude to democracy and recently I don't have the figures with me
but there was a very high proportion of young people who were prepared to say that democracy is in a very poor system
of government and some Knowles would be better.
Perhaps they meant an improved the other indicator is the growing number of young people who do not enrolled,
even though compulsion
and do not does so she she thought that she was close to giving up because you thought of all the efforts they've done
the poll figures get worse.
Take because boating is not compulsory is only compulsory to have the name marked off what you do with a piece of paper
then is entirely a matter for you. Yes question here is the right there are I don't disagree with your I would die.
He was that I make Carter,
as a kind of symbol of the ability of the chicks you want to Army what we want something to this.
This is a compact, I will go to the one more quick question
and then will have to finish right the VBAC Mister Marshall is a brief answers about the young I know my very brief
answer is convex, I think astray.
There can, by nineteen forty,
still doubted its right to its claim to be a nation because all the world if they knew one thing about Australia was
its low origins,
so I think the success which the rest of the world to the British acknowledged was so important to Australia that that
eclipsed everything else.
and As you say there is a wonderful story of Australia as an experiment in political democracy
and in social democracy is just got overwhelmed with that her that large in the eye was interested in the link between
mega cardinal rule of law sizes.
I do look at the speeches given in the Commonwealth Parliament in August nineteen fifteen cents after Anzac Day in
which the rationale for Australia entering the war was given.
Now the immediate exclamation was to assist a request by the British who asked by the King of the Belgians to resist
invasion of their country by the Germans, but then the Prime Minister,
the time went on to explain that we were there to defend some of our values,
and he listed some of those in honour of the use of Froebel we refer to C and its a wonderful speech in your letter.
Now, because it's on the Parliamentary website only talks about are the country being guided by night
and a number of other things. So it's clear they knew in the mines that some of those mental now. Today were at stake.
Rationalisation will know that a seventy believed in my view of about our Gallipoli is it's rather strange for the
biggest Mister Lawson.
This is
when Australia somehow became a nation now in an emotional sense that might well be true legally as people on this
panel no that's rubbish I me think about Federation nineteen oh one.
Not a nation that silly as interesting looking over the term nationals perspectives in relation World War I letter.
Many people.
He will use part of the British Empire
and there were many Australians in England who joined British Army fought as British officers are passive best-known SM
Bruce became Prime Minister here after World War I.
He was Australian fauna politically before is an officer that re- Shami so there was a sense that you will part of an
empire in a way it but I think people understandably more on the other hand,
there were some very influential people in Europe are a source as quite different and quite independent
and not least the then French President George, also in his name was our hurdle after the Battle of Hamill,
which was my ashes great victory.
We use what later became Blitzkrieg for the first time that, also got up
and addressed a great group of Australian soldiers
and said the French people something the effect of the French people have not observe what you done with your own
country and observe the development use.
Been able to undertake in your own country so weak when
when you came here we expect great things of you exactly gone on to astonish the whole blood bath.
but What what struck me is very intriguing about that is that people like Bruce with thinking empire breaking his neck
to get our Saint Kilda and go on laying lords and ladies on his left arm are the French President,
no less have very fine sense of the nation that Australians are built,
which was now being is not what is your the energy
and essence of that play now been transferred through these young soldiers to the defence of France.
Sorry I get going on that topic, the ad that around the time of Federation, there was actually,
French writing about the unique features of his training constitution was the French were very interested in,
so has been a tradition of policy, political
and also scholarly interests in the characteristics of the country which were told only came into existence nineteen
fifteen chooses right well bring things took place at this stage because I might know that people in the audience have
to disappear very soon after three o'clock before we go,
I would first of all like to thank our terrific speakers I mentioned in my preliminary remarks that I thought I would
learn a lot today. I have and in conversations with people at lunch, morning tea.
I'm sure that sentiment will be what she is so thank you again for being with this particular second,
I would like to library and the State librarian Doctor Alex Byrne.
This is a truly being you on the state might be is been very supportive of this particular occasion
and has with other things that the history Council has done of the district Council free much values the partnership.
I'd also like to repeat my thanks to the will of more institute in the magna Carter committee arm who really initiated
this
and to provide funding for a district council is very grateful to the will of Law Institute Eckhart committee for the
support of the enthusiasm and the knowledge that they provided
and I would also what's more like to the staff of the Council
and the person I took over promise President Richard Waterhouse,
who played a vital role in getting everything started to continue to look after the details of the arrangements right
through until the end before I finish I would like to thank you the audience some,
it's been a great audience are the questions have been very interesting and I'm sure like me you have enjoyed today,
so thanks once more